Mike Ehrmantraut is one of the
best-known and most loved supporting
actress in any TV show for his
unbelievable level-headedness as well as
words of wisdom Mike Ehrmantraut was
actually introduced to Breaking Bad as a
temporary replacement for a Saul Goodman
as Bob Odenkirk was unable to film for a
few episodes for Breaking Bad however
this 3 episode commitment would quickly
evolve into a full-fledged arc in season
3 of Breaking Bad as Mike will be
portrayed as Gus Frank's lead henchman
soon enough Jonathan banks would also be
portrayed in better call Saul as well
and was solidify a spot as a classic
Breaking Bad character but in a fiasco
as with clayey Gus and saw how much was
Mike actually able to make for his
granddaughter and daughter-in-law
Cillian Stacey
starting off with Mike's dealings with
player we know that he gets $1,500 for
each time he backs a player or Daniel in
one of his dealings with the nacho we
don't exactly know how many times Mike
backs up Daniel but we know that it's
just a handful of times before Daniel
decides to get a Hummer causing both
Mike and nacho to be unwilling to do
business with them we'll just say that
around five deals go down before this
happens allowing for Mike to profit
7,500 ollars but that's not it from
player Mike also helps facilitate a deal
between playa and nacho where Daniel
trades a Hummer for the baseball cards
and Mike gets a 10k cut Mike's first
encounter with good money is when he
charges nacho 50k to take our taco
however this full amount doesn't
actually materialize in the way you
would think Mike actually lowers the
amount at 25k to put Coco and Jill
rather than kill him nacho actually pays
Mike this amount but Mike returns a full
amount when he helps hector salamanca
get to go out of joe earlier though he
doesn't pop anything from nacho mike is
able to get the full 50k he originally
wanted from Hector pushing up his pre
Gus earnings 260 $7,500 in the meantime
he does have some dealings with Jimmy
like stealing from the kettlemans but
none of these actually left any money
for Mike
moving on to when Mike hits it big with
the Gus his first job for Gus is getting
Hector's truck stopped by Porter
security and shutting now Hector's flow
from the south this is a pretty big deal
as this gives Gus control over Hector
and we would expect Mike to be paid well
and he is as it seems like he gets about
30k from Victor for doing this
however classic Mike returns a money as
he did the job for his own morals and
not for Gus later on Mike realizes that
he has a lot of money that he can't
spend so he goes to Gus to get help
laundering his money in this
conversation he reveals that he has made
about $200,000 from his criminal
activities thus far so it looks like
there's roughly another 130 $2,500 in
pre Gus earning for Mike Mike's first
long-term project with the Gus is
leading the construction of the super
lab we don't really know how much Gus
pays Mike for this job
it's likely a good amount but not too
high because though this job has several
logistical risks there's no real danger
to his or the team safety so it's
unlikely that he gets paid six figures
per month to lead the project
considering that mike has a history of
charging 50k we'll just say he gets paid
50k per month with the project lasting
roughly six months before Werner Ziegler
escapes causing him to stop and postpone
the project Mike would have made about
300k during this time and this would be
the point that Mike would fully become
Gus's right-hand man considering that
season five of better call Saul takes
place between April and June of 2004
well say that Mike starts working for
Gus in May of 2004 this arrangement
would basically continue up until Walter
starts working for Gus in March of 2009
which would skyrocket their profits in
the meantime we know from the how much
does Gus fring make video that Gus fring
was pushing around 100 pounds per week
and 1700 per ounce we also know that
after accounting for all costs Gus would
have about 10% of the total revenue to
pay his right-hand men Gus has many
henchmen but his main three are Victor
this dude and Mike so it would make
sense that the main guys get about 5% of
revenue and all of Gus's other men get
the other 5% if the five percent is
split equally Mike would get one point
six six percent of the total revenue
with the total revenue being ten point
eight eight million per month
Mike's cut would be about 180 one
thousand dollars per month but there are
properly production issues here and
there and we want to has to make
conservatively so we'll just say Mike
gets 150 thousand dollars per month
during this time period which works out
to eight point seven million dollars
during the four months that Walter works
for Gus Walter is able to up Gus's
production to 200 pounds per week at a
higher $2,500 per ounce allowing for
eight million dollars in revenue per
week this would significantly increase
my cut to about five hundred thousand
dollars per month this amount actually
makes sense as Mike reveals that Walter
makes more than him unfortunately
however this only lasts for four months
but Mike would have still got a solid to
mind our income in this time period
putting his total income and
7.2 million but that's not it aside from
working for Gus full-time we know that
Mike works as a private investigator for
Saul we don't know when saw opens his
legal practice but assuming that
sometime in 2005 or 2006 Mike would have
worked for Saul for about four to five
years Saul doesn't need too much
investigator work so estimating that
Saul uses Mike about four times a year
at 20k per job this would provide Mike
with another three hundred and twenty
thousand dollars putting him at about
11.5 million dollars finally we have
Mike's partnership with Walter and Jesse
they didn't actually end up cooking one
full batch which gave them each one
hundred thirty seven thousand dollars
but soon enough Jesse and Mike would
decide on cashing out and selling their
portions of the methylamine selling the
methylamine would bring in five million
dollars from Mike putting his total
income up to sixteen point six three
million Mike does take care to full
legacy payments however so we'll just
say that about a third of his fine
minorca went towards this meaning that
Mike would be left with right about
fifteen million dollars it might be a
little more or a little less but Mike
likely made about fourteen to sixteen
million dollars during Breaking Bad and
better call Saul and though he isn't
able to leave behind the multi-million
dollar inheritance for Kili as he hoped
out of all the characters in the show he
is able to best spend the money as he is
able to splurge hundreds of thousands if
not millions on his granddaughter and
daughter-in-law for several years before
he dies furthermore he is able to
strengthen his relationship with them
after the death of his son leaving them
off on a good note and no one can
confiscate that do you guys also think
that the criminal money most helped Mike
makes your comment that down below also
if you guys thought this video provided
a detailed analysis on Mike's income
then make sure drop a like and consider
subscribing to see more questions
logically answered but until then I'm
Horry I'll see you guys on the next one